après les lettres piégées donc reçu
notamment par l'Ambassade du crâne en
Espagne des paquets ensanglantés ils
contenaient notamment des yeux d'animaux
plusieurs représentations diplomatiques
de l'Ukraine ont eu la mauvaise surprise
de recevoir de nouveaux colis pour le
moins INAMI quo nous cherchons à
comprendre la signification de ce
message voilà ce qu'a déclaré ces
dernières heures le ministre ukrainien
des Affaires étrangères bonjour Julien
Garrel vous êtes donc notre
correspondant à Madrid cette fois-ci il
ne s'agit plus que de l'Espagne
oui effectivement même si l'Espagne
semble être un petit peu
l'épicentre on va dire de cette vague
d'intimidation et de et de menaces
puisque il y a deux jours déjà
l'ambassade d'Ukraine à Madrid avait
reçu une première lettre piégée et
aujourd'hui donc le périmètre autour de
cette même ambassade
ukrainienne à Madrid a été totalement
bouclée un peu plus d'une heure et demie
entre 14h20 et 16h environ en raison on
vous l'avez dit de la réception d'une
nouvelle lettre suspecte alors
contrairement à celle arrivée il y a 48
heures il y avait blessé d'ailleurs un
employé de l'ambassade en 100 flamand
celle-ci ne contenait pas de mécanisme
pyrotechnique mais elle était tâchée de
sang des sources au ministère de
l'Intérieur ont également précisé que la
lettre n'avait pas été affranchie en
Espagne sans pour autant donner plus de
détails mais cela fait déjà une deuxième
différence avec les lettres piégées
reçues jusqu'ici qui était au nombre de
six qui elle avait été envoyé depuis le
territoire national et l'autre
information importante de la journée on
va sortir un petit peu des frontières
espagnoles c'est que six autres
ambassades ukrainienne à travers
l'Europe ont reçu aujourd'hui ce même
type de lettre ensanglanté en Italie au
Pays-Bas en Hongrie en Pologne en
Croatie et en Autriche certains colis
contre les mêmes des yeux d'animaux il
n'y a donc maintenant plus vraiment de
doute sur le fait que toutes ces lettres
toutes ces colis font partie d'une
campagne planifiée d'intimidation de
l'Ukraine et de ses soutiens c'est ce
qui a déclaré un porte-parole du
gouvernement ukrainien qui est renforce
donc plus que jamais la sécurité dans
toutes ses représentations diplomatiques
tandis que en Espagne une enquête pour
des faits présumés de terrorisme et
toujours en cours